So there's going to be
these two post conditions,
one having to do with the new
link in the association and
the other one having to do with
contingently updating the request list.
So we'll consider the first
post condition here.
What we're really saying is that there's
going to be a new CheckOut record.
Another way of saying that is there
must exist a new CheckOut record, and
in fact, there's that
keyword in OCL called exists.
So, the post condition here is going
to say there's going to exist, and
this is just like in our first
order logic where we had
the leftward facing capital letter E.
That there's a bound variable
in this case we'll call it C.
So there's a new link
in that association,
the association's name checked out,
okay?
With the properties that
the that-links-loanable items had better
be the item that we're checking out
which was the argument to the operation.
And the properties that we wish
to hold about that CheckOut,
that is the due date,
had better be correct.
And to get the due date,
we can go get today's date, and
then we can add in the checkoutPeriod.
And remember,
we have the checkoutPeriod,
that was one of the first
requirements we dealt with in OCL.
And we can go get that
checkoutPeriod by navigating from
the CheckOut link to
the corresponding loanableItem,
and then getting its checkoutPeriod.
That says there must
exist this new item and
it also better be the case
that the checkedOut
association itself must
have a new item in it.
And the way we do that in,
either first door logic or in OCL,
is to make a statement of
the quality between the state that
existed before the CheckOut operation,
and the state that existed afterwards.
So the state that exists
afterwards is just checkedOut.
You can think of that a set
of records or a set of links.
But need some special
notation to deal with
the state of the checkedOut
association beforehand.
And OCL has a keyword, and
it's indicated by the @
followed by the word pre.
So this is saying checkout@pre means the
version before we call the operation,
and CheckOut by itself means
the version afterwards.
And there's an operation on sets, and
checkedOut is a set,
it's a set of links,
that allows us to indicate
that another element
is associated with that particular set.
And that keyword is including.
So it's as if we
are constructing a new set,
which is the old set,
plus this one new item.
Actually this one new checkedOut link,
which we've given the name C.
So, we have the checkedOut afterwards
is equal to the checkedOut before,
and this one other item
which we've just added, and
that's what's being expressed
on the bottom line there.
So we're making use of some
special keywords and operations
in the OCL language to express
the equality of these two states.
>> So I've got a quick question.
Can we also consider the @pre
including kind of be like set union,
so we're unioning the set of all
of our checkedOut associations
plus this new checked-out association.
>> Almost, but this item, I'm sorry,
this new checkedOut link is not a set.
Its just an element.
If we had somehow been able
to wrap it in some set thing,
then it would be unique.
>> A set containing this new element.
>> And
what I think Jared is pointing out here,
is we have to be careful in getting
the data types right in these things.
So, a set is different
than an element and
if you had a union operation you
couldn't put an element on it.
And if you had including you
couldn't put a set on it.
That was the first post condition having
to do with updating the checkedOut
association.
The second one had to do with
the requests that were made.
We had a precondition that said if
there are requests then it'd better be
the case that Jared is
the one doing the requesting.
Now we need to update that
request list if it exists,
and with the fact that we want
to take Jared off that list.
We don't want him to
hog the book too long.
So, in this case, the post condition
is going to make use of another
feature of OCL called
the LET expression.
And the LET expression
is just an abbreviation.
It allows us to state in one place,
an expression, and
then use it in several places.
So in this case we're saying let
the new variable t of type Title
be that title of the current item.
We distinguish between items, which
are things that could be checked out
from the things the things that could
be requested, which we called titles.
But an item always has a title,
that's the composition operator
that we see in the diagram.
And we just want to use
the shorthand of t for
item.title to save ourselves a few
characters every time we type.
So the let expression there defines
the new symbol, and binds it during
the scope of another expression,
which is the post condition.
And the post condition here is
conditional as to be expected.
So if that particular title
has a request to this particular patron.
And then we want to update
the request association.
So the antecedent
of the conditional is
t.request.patron and
if we didn't have t,
we'd have i.title.request.patron,
it'd be either three or four steps
in the chain of qualified name and
includes is a operation
on that set of requests.
And self is the OCL
keyword corresponding to
the instance of the particular class.
And remember that was way
back with the Patron.
So we're seeing whether or
not Jared is in the list of
people during the requesting.
And if so,
we want to do another one of these
statements of equality between the state
before and the state afterwards.
So, the state afterwards is
the request association and
the state before is request at pre.
And, in this case it's not that
we're adding in a new record,
it's that we want to remove it.
But, it's a statement of equality so
were stating that by saying
If we, and
the key word in OCL is reject.
If we reject those
particular items in the list
which have the following boolean.
And the boolean is, the title is t,
and patron is self.
Then we have a version of
the request association without that
one record in it and that had
better equal to the one afterwards.
If there were no requests with
Jared at the top of the list,
then our result is true.
Okay, so
we don't have to be concerned there.
So the overall post condition constraint
has the form of the let binding,
and then within that a conditional.
And the conditional, we're only
interested in the then part of it,
which is qualified by whether or
not Jared has done the requesting.
And in which case we want to ensure
that Jared's request is no longer in
In that particular association.
>> So do you have a recommendation
on this if then statement?
because this if then statement, the else
is kind of a vacuously true situation.
So wouldn't it just be better to use
an imply statement to save yourself
some writing?
>> Good point.
So yeah, we could shorten
the situation by doing the implies.
I had on other question.
>> Sure.
>> If that's all right.
So I guess, are all associations
that are modeled in our UML diagram,
can they be thought of when we're
expressing things in OCL as sets.
because it seems like
express t.request.patron,
this is an association.
We're talking about the patron
part of the association.
The set of all patrons that
have requested things, or
in which a request instance is there,
is modeled in a set.
>> Okay, so
you can think of them as sets, but
sometimes we can do a little bit better.
So we call that in UML,
those the ability to order things.
And in order things,
then we get sequences.
So sequences give us a little more
power because we can index into them.
>> Okay.
>> Whereas with sets you can't index
into them, right?
So, now a sequence is a set, but
a sequence, because it has this ordering
with it, allows us a little more power.
>> And that's going to be based
on the model that we have,
whether we modeled it that way or
as a set.
>> The properties, the requirements,
and whether we modeled it that way.
>> Okay.